hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña alex castillo fundador de
transformación hablamos de el primer
colectivo de hombres trans en
centroamérica y también es presidente de
la red de colectivos americanos de
hombres trans y junto a él vamos a
abordar un tema muchas veces
invisibilizado me refiero al embarazo y
el aborto trans masculino alex castillo
muchísimas gracias por estos minutos en
france 24 en español
hola mucho gusto en nuestro álex bueno
cuando se habla de aborto se suele
pensar en mujeres si es género a verdad
y los hombres trans o personas no
binarias asignadas al género femenino al
momento de nacer entonces quedan por
fuera de lo que es ese imaginario
colectivo pero no solo de los
imaginarios también de los estudios de
las estadísticas y por sobre todo y algo
muy importante clave de las
legislaciones también es importante
recordar que hay varones trans que
mantienen prácticas sexuales de las que
pueden resultar un embarazo pero también
transitan embarazos no deseados frutos
de agresiones sexuales usted mismo gesto
en dos oportunidades y no fue su
decisión verdad usted sufrió la
violencia por tener un cuerpo asignado
femenino al momento de nacer lo
obligaron a casarse de manera correctiva
verdad cómo fue esa experiencia alex
cuando provoca por lo general en este
tipo de países donde el cuerpo asignado
femenino al nacer como que tiene que
cumplir una cierta función horror
que es el de gestar el de reproducción
en mi caso yo soy la excepción
creo que los estudios que hemos
realizado nos demuestran que la mayoría
de hombres atrás o personas recientes de
generación femeninas al nacer que hemos
sufrido de algún tipo de abuso sexual y
es precisamente por tratar de corregir
ese momento él
el fantasma que que se tiene verdad es
que este cuerpo tiene que estar y que
con eso lo corregiríamos y pues en mi
caso no fue la excepción fue así como
esa
amo siempre me da me toco
que aceptar este tipo de violencia
verdad y que hizo que efectivamente me
casarán a muy temprana edad
creo que el desconocimiento en general
de la temática y hace que se en este
tipo de situaciones y sobre todo que que
se siga violentando la identidad de
género especialmente en las trans
masculinidades entonces pues si un
gestante dos veces verdad hoy por hoy
pues ya mis hijos son adultos
y tengo una hermosa pero eso hizo que me
transitar hacia el género con el cual yo
me identifico como el canal masculino
llegará hasta los 44 años en esa
violencia no hacia las identidades auto
percibidas por suerte tienen un rol muy
poroso por sámano de alguna manera de lo
que son las violaciones correctivas
verdad
así es así se le llama violación
correctiva y es más común de lo que
ustedes se puedan imaginar
en un estudio que hicimos en guatemala
donde participaron 50 hombres trans el
80 por ciento de los encuestados había
sufrido una violencia
de diferentes índoles programa your
marcada era esta la violación correctiva
y cuéntenos cómo es la experiencia de
paternal como un hombre trans tuvo usted
que hacer a un lado su identidad de
género
así es porque obviamente me obligaron
prácticamente a asumir un rol mi
identidad yo mismo no sabía que era un
hombre tras dos estamos hablando de que
en los años 90 pues se hablaba del tema
y pues como un fracaso fracaso y que lo
que me tocó es suspender mi misión y
dedicarme a mantener a los niños porque
prácticamente se llevan como dos años
mis hijos y me tocó hacer el rol de papá
de mamá
siguiente hecho fue en fin me tocó un
sismo errores con ellos y que al final
de la historia
es precisamente renunciar a uno mismo
porque la responsabilidad entretenía de
dos niños y ahora tenía que sacar
adelante a como diera lugar entonces en
la última persona que uno piense ese
mundo porque ya tengo una
responsabilidad que cumplir 10 hasta la
vejez de mis hijos y cada uno decide
hacer su vida y es cuando yo empiezo a
pensar un poquito en mí y hacer esa
transición que tengo pues desde el año
2013 en transiciones parten tres años
álex como decíamos al comienzo de la
entrevista la práctica de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
suele estar asociada por lo menos en el
imaginario colectivo a mujeres y género
verdad y si para ellas es difícil no
acceder a la interrupción del embarazo
siento que como decíamos están
integradas al imaginario colectivo no
como las personas que legítimamente por
decirlo de alguna manera abortan como es
para la masculinidad es trans que
obstáculos concretos se enfrentan
bueno lo primero es que en el área
centroamericana en toda el área en la
volta les es penalizado
está analizado y es con cárcel de 6 años
en adelante
entonces el hablar de un aborto para una
mujer sin género pues es un tabú por
completo ahora en un cuerpo gestante
masculina
porque se desconoce la temática
solamente se cree que uno debe cumplir
esa obligación esma eso te está
predicando permanentemente lo que el
pecado porque el pecado es algo con lo
cual se manejan nuestras legislaciones
es como si dios te dio la bendición de
estar un hijo no le vas a dar vida en
fin se volverá una una cuestión muy
fuerte con mucha presión por todos lados
verdad porque acá mi hijo lo ven como
una bendición y nuestra legislación dice
que la vida se defiende desde el momento
de su concepción entonces imagínate lo
duro que es y muy atraen ese imaginario
y qué bueno llega a gestar y uno mismo a
romperse un aborto es como el mayor
pecado que va ser condenado infierno y
encima sumarlo a eso el hecho de irte a
una presión si te hará descubrir y su
mentor haga eso un aborto exportar yo en
este tipo de expresiones masculina sólo
lleva al servicio público y es para que
te regresen a tu casa y tenían que
estarlo definitivamente se volvimos
estando
ahora más allá de lo que es la práctica
del aborto a que se enfrenta a un varón
trans una masculinidad trans cuando
acude al sistema de salud los análisis y
ginecológicos por ejemplo son
importantes no para muchas identidades
masculinas trans y se conocen muchísimos
casos de muchísimas personas que no
visitan al médico
no precisamente porque no hay médicos
médicas que tengan el experticia en el
tema entonces por ejemplo nosotros nos
hemos topado con que solo el hecho que
tú ya te presentes a una clínica
empresas de sufrir el estímulo y la
discriminación desde la secretaria o la
recepcionista que te atiende en estos
países donde no existen leyes de
identidad de género que si por en
algunos países podemos cambiarnos el
nombre ya el hecho que yo llegué con
esta expresión tan masculina a solicitar
un papanicolau me empiezan a ver como
loco y de hecho a muchas de mis
compañeras se les ha negado se les ha
negado el hecho a poderse hacer un
examen de rutina un papanicolau de hecho
a mí me tocó realizar una histerectomía
de emergencia y créanme que el juego de
la carrera contra mi vida y era de
urgencia era de urgencia que había que
realizarme la y fue
suele ser por lo privado
tuve que conseguir el dinero mejor
confrontar cualquier clase de estigma
discriminación para que me pusiera con
pena al examen y ahora de algunos
estereotipos o mitos por llamarlo de
alguna manera no en torno al género y a
la reproducción a la salud reproductiva
hay una suerte de creencia según la cual
la masculinidad es trans los hombres
trans son estériles verdad esto está
bastante generalizado o no y hay así
prejuicios culturales pero también hay
cierto respaldo legal no porque las
políticas de esterilizaciones forzadas
han sido una realidad en muchísimos
países de américa latina cuál es la
situación hoy en día con respecto a esta
práctica
si en
centroamérica como tal como no existe ni
protocolos ni leyes ni ningún rock y
reconocimiento hacia las identidades
trans pues realmente no
tú puedes empezar incluso somos tan
irresponsables muchos tengo muchos de
los que conozco que empiezan a
autorizarse en esa
necesidad de hacer esta transición pero
recordemos el cada cuerpo es diferente y
el hecho que tú te estés armonizando no
significa que que ya dejaste de demain
situar por lo tanto no pueden llegar a
ser un cuerpo constante muere otro grito
y la creencia es que a todos los hombres
carlos gustan solo las mujeres que somos
heterosexuales demasiado con nuestras
prácticas sexuales son tan diversas como
lo son el resto de la
población y sumemos a eso el tema de la
educación no acompañamiento
y empatía por parte de los estados pues
hace de que existamos los dos cuerpos
restantes transmedia pero es un rito no
en ningún momento y derecho muchos de
los cuerpos que están detrás masculinos
que hay y la variante en américa latina
la mayoría es por violencia no por
decisión propia ahora el momento de
abortar se enfrentan además a una suerte
de doble clandestinidad verdad por un
lado la de un procedimiento ilegal no y
por otro lado la que supone negar su
propia identidad de género para no
profundizar el maltrato esto porque
llegan a simular ser mujeres no para
evitar las violencias
sin mira para empezar desde que entras
te empiezan a tratar en femenino
no respetan tu nombre sino que te
empiezan a ver como muy muy raro de
hecho nosotros tuvimos un caso de un
compañero que tuvo un aborto espontáneo
y lo que hicieron en el hospital fue
decirle que no lo podían atender y solo
lo mandaron con un pequeño tratamiento
para el dolor y le tocó hacer el
procedimiento en un aborto espontáneo
prácticamente en el sol y fueron dolores
y fue poner en riesgo su vida y fue un
momento bastante traumático y difícil de
hecho nosotros pues creemos que tenemos
la gran dicha de contar con la primera
clínica de atención integral para
hombres trans y desde ahí en
transformación de guatemala y ese es el
país pionero y que la doctora que es una
doctora la que nos acompaña le toca
atender a muchos países de la región por
línea y por videollamadas
a subir esta gran necesidad y este gran
vacío que hay en américa latina con
respecto a la temática y sobre todo con
los profesionales de salud que conozcan
y quieran trabajar con el tema y me
estaba refiriendo a la salud integral y
en general verdad desde una ats una
prueba de vih para un hombre trans es un
privilegio a nosotros no nos dan porque
no somos indicadores nos dicen entonces
prácticamente estamos en el desierto en
el abandono y esta clínica se ha vuelto
como el pequeño haces para muchos de
nosotros
álex castillo se nos acabó el tiempo
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
estos minutos siempre dan 24 en español
no el gusto ha sido nuestro a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
que sigan informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto un france24 puntocom sigan con
nosotros
[Música]